hey guys it's me jasmine lately i've
been doing as a lot of people do
scrolling through tik tok for hours on
end i personally watch a lot of food
videos and i just keep saving them as if
i'm gonna do every single recipe and i
just don't have the time but today we
are making the time we are going to try
three vegan asian recipes that have gone
viral on tik tok they look absolutely
delicious so first we're going to be
doing the bubble potato pillows then
we're going to look at the vegan unagi
don't then the salt and pepper flour
mushrooms let's get started so these are
the bubble potatoes from miss she and mr
hee this video has
63.7
million views that is
insane okay let's watch it
okay they look beautifully crispy and
soft and fluffy on the inside oh fun
hack okay oh that looks so satisfying so
we're definitely gonna do that okay
garlic press to press the potatoes oh my
god
okay now it's looking like gnocchi oh
that looks so good really yummy yes some
cayenne okay let's make it i'm ready all
right so first we're starting with the
crunchy bubble potato pillows i have all
the ingredients here let's get started
we're gonna start with these two
potatoes these are russet potatoes she
did this really cool hack where she
very
slightly cut down the waist of the
potato
not all the way through this is supposed
to help it peel better so that's what i
am doing here i guess that's good
okay one more
i'm really excited to see how this hack
turns out
okay so now to my pot of water we're
just gonna bring this to a boil
come on you're embarrassing me
ah there we go once this comes to a boil
we're gonna drop our potatoes in and
then cook them for about 30 minutes
until they're fork tender our potatoes
are soft okay so i've prepared our ice
bath here we're gonna pop it in there
let's see
that was satisfying
that's a good hack okay so i'm gonna
finish peeling these and then we're
going to cut them i'm going to quarter
all of these so it can fit into my
garlic press i literally bought it just
for this because i usually just mash
potatoes with my fork and i think it's
really interesting that she mashes it
with a garlic press so let's do it i'm
gonna put a piece of potato in there
wow that is so satisfying and so much
easier than actually pressing garlic
next time i'm stressed i'm gonna just be
making these potato pillows pressing
these taters through my garlic press
it's so fluffy i have a finish pressing
all my potatoes through my garlic press
look at it it looks so much like hash
browns we could easily take a detour
right now but we won't i'm adding two
tablespoons of glutinous rice flour
which actually doesn't contain gluten
glutinous is in that name to describe
the textures now we're gonna add in one
tablespoon of cornstarch a third
teaspoon of salt a third teaspoon of
black pepper i'm mixing everything
together with my hands you can feel how
well everything integrates together i'm
gonna transfer on to my surface so i'm
gonna continue kneading this until it's
smooth
all right
our potato dough is ready it is so
smooth
okay so what she does is she shapes it
she says you could do whatever shape you
want but i'm just gonna do what she did
um so i'm gonna cut a piece off here i'm
gonna roll it into a little log to
lengthen my dough whenever i'm rolling
it out like that i'll start with my
palms flat and then as i roll i'll start
spreading my fingers
section off my dough and i'm going to
take my fork just going to press it
and i'm gonna continue pressing out the
rest of my potato pillows i got the hang
of it
more pressure up top less pressure at
the bottom
gorgeous so i have my first batch done
here i'm gonna press down on the rest of
these until i've used up all my dough so
i've heated up some oil here's a hack i
like to use i know when my oil is ready
when i stick a chopstick in there and it
starts to bubble
do you see that it's ready for frying
i'm gonna put a few potatoes on my
this
so we're gonna add our potatoes into our
oil once your oil hits 350 we're gonna
fry for about five minutes until they're
lightly
golden
i'm gonna fry it in batches because it
looks like they are
in love with each other and they can't
keep their hands off each other so
i don't want that to happen
all right these are looking nice and
light golden so i'm gonna take them out
i just lined one of my baking sheets
with paper towels so the excess oil can
drain we're gonna do a double fry so
we're gonna add all of our potato
pillows back into the pan and fry for
another 30 seconds and take them back
out voila shall we do a crunch test nice
and crispy
i'm gonna transfer my potatoes onto this
plate you'll see that the towels have
helped soak up that excess oil i'm gonna
add on a little bit of cayenne
we're gonna give it a little
toss lastly i'm just gonna serve it with
some ketchup the bubble potatoes are
done potatoes that over 63 million
people have seen get some ketchup
the outside is super crunchy and the
inside is super fluffy and creamy
with the cayenne and dipped in ketchup
that sweet and spicy just gives it that
perfect kick for this recipe i'm just
gonna have to give it a 10 out of 10.
it's so good let's move on to the next
one the vegan unagi don our second
recipe is this vegan unagi dong which is
the eel
made from eggplant i actually have made
something similar with my friend merle
over on good full it was absolutely
delicious so i'm excited to try this
recipe this vegan unagi done recipe is
from okonomi kitchen let's watch the
video
i mean right off the bat it already
straight up looks like eel okay i got my
rice going already
we're gonna steam our eggplant so it
looks like she butterflied the eggplant
spread it with her fingers i'm really
excited about this one let's get started
so first to make the eel which is made
out of eggplant today we're gonna need
three japanese eggplants or two chinese
eggplants um my eggplant today is
extremely long and in this case i would
say size matters and we'll only need one
so we're gonna remove the tip i learned
this tip from merle you don't need to
just cut off the tip we're wasting flesh
here you just take that little leaf
peel it upwards minimize the food waste
and then now you only need to cut this
part off i've definitely seen some
videos where people are cutting off this
much eggplant and it's all good stuff in
there i'm gonna cut this in half and now
we're just gonna steam it for five
minutes flipping it halfway through all
right our eggplant has finished steaming
let's remove it
we're going to butterfly the eggplant so
we're gonna slice in but not all the way
through
and we are going to peel it
outwards oh okay this is working no this
was great okay perfect now she flattens
it now we're going to do the same thing
with this guy here that looks great i
kind of cut through that one but let's
just pretend i didn't so now she creates
little horizontal cuts this looks so
good
our eggplant is ready and now we are
going to dust it with some potato starch
now we are going to pan fry them i'm
going to do them one at a time about two
to three minutes on each side until
there's a little bit of a char
and then we're gonna make the sauce in
the same pan there's an option to make
the sauce on the side keep it real nice
and neat but i'm a one pan kind of gal
just keep it simple do less dishes me
and eggplant have come a very long way i
used to have such a strong hatred
towards it i didn't like the flavor the
texture but then i had the chinese
garlic eggplant and now i love it in
everything i always say if you don't
like a food and it's been three years
give it another try
our flavor palettes are always expanding
all right let's give this a flip right
now the eggplant is sticking to the pot
if you just let it sit and crispify
you'll be able to move it in like just a
couple minutes so i always recommend
just leaving it once it's stuck
and let's repeat it with this second one
and we're just gonna do the same thing
and then we'll make the sauce to make
the sauce we're gonna add some sake some
marin and dashi powder so once that
dashi is all dissolved i'm gonna add in
some cane sugar and some soy sauce i
want this mixture to thicken to about
this texture and now we're gonna add
back in our eggplant
get that beautifully coated up in the
sauce and finally we're just gonna add
nori rice sauce our eggplant and finally
topped with some toasted sesame seeds
this looks so good honestly really looks
a lot like eel let's give this a try
that is so epping good if you're at home
you're not going to make any of these
you got to make this the moisture and
the juice the eggplant gives off is so
complementary with the fluffy rice and
also the eggplant has had that chance to
soak up all of that sauce it's like in
perfect harmony 10 out of 10. let's move
on to the next one salt and pepper flour
mushrooms so the next one we're moving
on to is the salt and pepper flour
mushrooms from wound hung
these look so cool it reminds me of
popcorn chicken kind of but with
mushrooms and like texture heaven with
all these crisscrosses let's watch the
video
it looks so good a flower for me thank
you
see i just already can't wait to do that
it looks so fun and then coating it in
the cornstarch all the crispy bits my
gosh
peppers all thrown together if you've
ever had a dry pot a dry hot pot it's
like dry seasonings
love so good reminds me like chicken
wings when you do a dry rub
oh spicy and peppery salivating again i
think i chose some really good recipes
today let's do it all right so i have my
king oyster mushrooms here i am obsessed
with these these are so good we're just
gonna cut the tips off i like to take
any veggie scraps put them in the
freezer and if i'm making a veggie stock
i'll just combine all those scraps i
have to make a really rich broth so
cutting the last tips off here
and what we're gonna do with these is
cut them into two and a half inch slices
and last one so now is that cool trick
that she did i've done this with
potatoes once before and it was really
fun okay so what we're gonna do is line
chopsticks on either side of the
mushroom like this we're going to cut
until we hit the chopstick so it doesn't
go all the way through
all right so now we turn it around this
way and same thing
i'm being really careful not to cut any
pieces off
wow look at that
sorry you have triple phobia i can see
if this will trigger you but i think it
looks cool
i'm just going gonna finish cutting
these and then we'll move on to the next
step so i've cut all my mushrooms and
created my beautiful florets so i have
just kidding it's not boiling
[Laughter]
we are going to place our florets in
there uncut side down and then we're
just gonna cook them for about three to
five minutes until it turns from white
to like a little grayish color oh
they're blossoming how cute the
mushrooms look slightly gray i'm just
going to take them out
and we're going to squeeze out any
excess moisture i can already tell if i
did it right now i'd burn my fingers
which i do often because i don't have
any patience but anyway this isn't about
me i've let the mushrooms chill a little
bit gently press on it to remove that
extra moisture because of all the little
crevices we made with the slicing
there's just going to carry a lot of
extra moisture and you want to get that
out so it can be crispy so now we're
going to add our mushroom flowers to our
cornstarch mixture which just has some
salt black pepper and white pepper and i
just mixed it all together now we're
gonna toss in the mushrooms i'm just
gonna get that all
coated open it up coat it in all the
crevices
look at that nice and coated i'm gonna
dust off any excess corn starch and then
place it in our oil oh my gosh
beautiful
i don't want to do too many at a time
because i scared they're gonna stick
together
okay so we're gonna fry these until
they're golden brown
are you a mushroom person please let me
know in the comments because you know
when i was in third grade my teacher she
was like okay everyone's gonna come up
here and tell us your favorite food i
went up and said mushrooms and the whole
class said ew
but i remember that moment so clearly
these look great
i'm gonna add some more
don't touch each other
like an r.a in college okay these look
done look how pretty it is it literally
looks like a flower put it on my paper
lined plate here to drain that extra oil
we're gonna make the dry rub the dry
seasonings i'm gonna add some oil to my
pan here oil's hot let's toss in the
garlic red chili scallions salt white
pepper and some black pepper the colors
are so vibrant let's toss in our
mushrooms that we just fried
so the best method is to toss it gently
okay this is all done so last step is to
just drizzle some sesame oil over it
don't overdo it like if i was having
movie night with my friends and we were
eating dinner and stuff this would be
like the perfect appetizer
or side dish of the meal the mushrooms
are finally done they look beautiful i
mean they do straight up look like
flowers which is very very impressive to
me let's get to eating
you hear the crunch this reminds me of
popcorn chicken
there's a lot of peppers in here it's
not actually too spicy it's definitely
more of a peppery kick the scallions and
the sesame help neutralize everything
and the crisp and the mushroom oh my
gosh it tastes like chicken
honestly there's nothing i would do to
change this dish
it is perfect as is the bubble potato
pillows were deliciously crispy on the
outside creamy in the center the vegan
unagi don oh my gosh the eggplant
the juice from it it was so so good
paired with the rice and the sauce it
was just
chef's kiss and of course the salt and
pepper flour mushrooms crispy peppery
nutty so so good all right guys thanks
so much for watching all these dishes
were so good 10 out of 10 for all of
them if you plan on making any of them
the links are in the description snap a
picture tag me on instagram because i
want to see bye guys
you